to the ice it is do or die time for the
vegas golden knights tonight is game
seven over at the fortress t-mobile
arena
getting to the second round of the
playoffs means getting through the
minnesota wild who've won the last two
games in the series
kevin martin is live this afternoon over
near city national arena
as the knights get ready for a very big
game hi kevin
well hey you know it's the best two
words in sports
game seven it's a winner take all
scenario between the golden knights
and the wild the winner of course
advancing to the second round of the
stanley cup playoffs
while the loser well they head home it's
the first time
ever game seven will be played at the
fortress and as you can bet the roughly
12 000 fans that will be in attendance
will have the place rocket you know
they're not going to disappoint us
uh with what they're going to bring you
know from an energy and atmosphere point
of view and
you know frankly that that's why we
pushed so hard during the regular season
for
to you know to make sure that you have
the ability to have these type of uh
moments and situations uh you know in
front of a crowd that's uh
supporting you like they do here so you
know that's not lost on us or our group
and
you know we're happy to be uh to be
playing there tonight
[Applause]
pete deboer has never lost in a game
seven
as a head coach as he looks to go 6-0
all time tonight as far as who we can
expect
on the ice still no official word on
braden mcnabb or
ryan reeves both of which were on the
nhl covet protocol list reeves was on
the ice this morning
at morning skate so of course that is a
good sign mark andre fleury was the
first goalie off the ice today
all signs pointing to another flower
start and net his seventh consecutive
postseason start this season the punk
drops between the golden knights and the
wild at
six o'clock at the fortress reporting
live at city national arena kevin martin
8 sports now